مركز الشهاب لحقوق الانسان السلطات
المصريه بارتكاب انتهاكات موسعه ضد
المعتقلين في داخل سجن بدر ثلاثه وقال
المركز الحقوقي ان السلطات المصريه تتعنت
منذ سبعه اعوام في منع الاهالي من زياره
ذويهم المعتقلين محذرا من ان عددا من
المعتقلين اقدم على الانتحار نتيجه
المعامله السيئه
واضاف المركز الحقوقي ان معتقلين داخل
السجن بداوا اضرابا احتجاجا على ظروف
اعتقالهم السيئه الامر الذي واجهته اداره
السجن بمزيد من التعسف والعنف
واكد المركز الحقوقي ان المرشد العام
لجماعه الاخوان دخل في اضراب كلي بسبب
المعامله السيئه من قبل اداره السجن له
وعدم الاستجابه له في الذهاب الى المستشفى
ومنعه من حضور الجلسات امام النيابه وكان
تقرير لوكاله رويتر سلط الضوء على ما
وصفها بانتهاكات حقوق الانسان في سجن بدر
واشار الى انه يتم حرمان النزلاء من
الرعايه الصحيه ويتم اخضاعهم لمعامله
عقابيه تشمل العزل